bom meu nome é maria ela eu sou
psicóloga eu tenho especialização em
neuropsicologia
eu também sou mãe eu tenho duas filhas
com a minha filha mais velha eu vivencio
todas as alegrias e frustrações de um
desenvolvimento típico e com a minha
filha mais nova que tem seis anos está
no espectro autista eu estou vivenciando
uma uma coisa muito especial muito
desafiador e apaixonante tanto como mãe
como psicóloga quando as pessoas sabem
que eu sou psicóloga que eu tenho uma
filha dentro do espectro do autismo
as pessoas falam aqui ótimo você
psicóloga neves e deve ter percebido já
no começo que ela tinha descobriu cedo
se faz terapia com ela em casa não nada
nada nada disso né então a minha filha
também atingiu todos os marcos
desenvolvimento até um e mail andou fifa
é engatinhou tudo no período esperado
com animei o meu marido começamos a
notar algo de diferente entre ela ea
nossa filha mais velha então ela era
muito agitada ela não falava há ainda
nenhuma palavra ela parecia que ela não
escutava a gente chamava chamava algumas
vezes ela responde outras não e aí
médicos pessoas amigas todo mundo fala
anel é assim mesmo é a personalidade
dela cada pessoa tem seu ritmo não é
porque sua filha mais velha falou com
ele meio que ela também vai falar
e assim foi indo eu nunca nunca
suspeitei que ela tivesse um transtorno
do espectro do autismo
apesar de ser psicóloga porque porque
durante a faculdade
eu tinha uma visão muito diferente do
autismo net aquela ideia de que a
criança tinha problema de vínculo com a
mãe que a criança fosse fechado em seu
mundo ficava fazendo aqueles movimentos
repetitivos e não era isso que eu tinha
em casa né eu tinha uma menina
sorridente sapeca super sapeca em a
primeira vez que eu suspeitei que ela
pudesse ter um trânsito
o espectro do autismo foi durante uma
aula o meu curso de especialização com o
professor marcos mercadante
eu considero que foi um privilégio para
mim ter descoberto isso através dele eu
fiquei fascinada nessa hora fiquei
fascinada e aterrorizada ao mesmo tempo
porque ele ia falando eu ia reconhecendo
a minha filha mas ao mesmo tempo doutor
marcos ele tinha uma visão muito
otimista né e então ele eu acho legal
essa e se inscrito da da primeira frase
que eu escrevi da aula dele ele falou
assim o tipo de cérebro que temos não é
o design de cérebro herdado
porém ele vem com uma grande
plasticidade muito disse ele fala nesse
dvd que foi lançado por essa ong que foi
idealizada por ele também como
neuropsicólogo comecei a tentar entender
como que é o cérebro no autismo e hoje
em dia o que a gente mais vê assim a
teoria podemos dizer que está mais em
alta é que as conexões cerebrais no
autismo são diferentes então assim de um
modo muito resumido as conexões de longa
distância ou seja que ligam partes
distantes do cérebro elas são menos
eficientes são fracas vamos dizer
e também existem hiperconectividade
determinadas áreas então com isso a
gente com essa deficiência das conexões
longas a gente pode pensar será que daí
vêm os défices cognitivos e sociais que
a gente vê no autismo e essa
hiperconectividade nas regiões
específicas talvez explique um pouco
aqueles talentos musicais matemáticos
então pra gente falar um pouco da
plasticidade legal entender como é o
desenvolvimento normal do cérebro então
a criança nasce cheia de neurônios
querendo se conectar que nem lá na aula
doutor marcos ele falou existe uma
influência genética né nesse formato
como nasce um cérebro algumas
predisposições só que são as
experiências com o mundo a relação com o
mundo que vai formando as conexões por
isso que cada cérebro é único
cada pessoa é única porque ninguém tem
exatamente as mesmas experiências na
mesma
da mesma forma na mesma ordem então a
criança nasce e com a relação dela com a
mãe com o mundo enfim ela vai formando
lá os caminhos dela dentro do cérebro as
conexões e acho que todo mundo aqui já
deve ter ouvido falar aquela expressão
que a criança uma esponja
então porquê porque nos primeiros cinco
anos de vida o cérebro é muito plástico
muito permeável então qualquer exposição
as conexões vamos formando rapidamente
rapidamente nem tão principal a criança
é uma esponja ela tudo está no ambiente
ela capta muito fácil
então o que acontece no cérebro dos
autistas né esse pesquisador da
califórnia doutor michael zammit ele sem
querer ele fazia estudos em laboratório
com animais e ele mapeava os disparos
dos neurônios e ele conseguia
identificar no cérebro por exemplo o
macaco mexeu o dedo ele conseguia ver
qual região do cérebro era disparado os
neurônios ele a mapeando e aí ele estava
realmente estudando a neuroplasticidade
mas antigamente acreditava-se que essa
essa neuroplasticidade acontecia somente
no início da vida nos primeiros cinco
anos principalmente ela terminava na
adolescência sem querer uma pesquisa ele
descobriu que dispute era possível
modificar uma rede neuronal uma conexão
é mesmo em indivíduos adultos e aí ele
começou a pesquisar e ele foi o primeiro
pesquisador a acusar o termo
neuroplasticidade em artigos científicos
então que ele hoje eu que ele acredita
sobre o autismo que as conexões das
pessoas com o transtorno do espectro do
autismo ela se consolidam muito cedo
enquanto nas pessoas de desenvolvimento
típico elas são consolidadas às vezes
até o fim existem vários momentos não
vou me estender aqui no início mas é até
mais ou menos uns 20
anos nos indivíduos autistas elas se
consolidam quando eles têm dois anos de
idade ou muito cedo e aí o cérebro fica
cheio de conexões pouco específicas e
super reforçados então por isso que fica
muito mais difícil das crianças
aprenderem novas coisas porque é que nem
nós adultos
todo mundo já percebeu isso já ouviu
falar é muito mais difícil aprender uma
segunda língua depois que a gente é
adulto ou aprender um esporte mas não é
impossível porque só que que acontece
requer muito mais esforço mais repetição
um modo diferente de aprender né então é
isso que ele fala que os indivíduos com
autismo eles
eles têm capacidade de aprender porém de
maneiras diferentes das usuais né
então voltando assim cada cérebro é
único é que nem falei das experiências e
as conexões uns forma então que quem
maior desafio para nós profissionais e
pais entender como o cérebro do seu
filho como ele processa melhores
informações visualmente verbalmente
no caso da minha filha é muito visual e
acho que a maioria dos autistas né
ele tem muita sensibilidade sensorial
ele tem muita sensibilidade ao som ao
toque ou ao contrário ou ele é pouco
sensível ele fica buscando chegando tudo
que é o caso da minha filha também então
a gente tem que entender isso pra saber
como acessar como ensinar
então assim dentro desse panorama pra
mim o que faz mais sentido do que está
dando mais resultado com a minha filha é
a análise do comportamento aplicada
porque porque é um programa que trabalha
incessantemente com repetições
eles estabelecem um programa de educação
individualizado usam suportes visuais
mas de acordo com a necessidade de cada
criança não tem um programa a aba igual
para essa criança para essa criança no
caso da minha filha é muito muito visual
ela ainda não fala fala poucas palavras
mas quando a gente mostra por exemplo a
eu
comer é uma bolacha
tá na hora do almoço a gente fala assim
não pode comer né
ela não funciona pra ela agora se eu
mostrar uma figura o primeiro você vai
comer a comida depois você ganha bolacha
ela continua brava mas r verde
ela funciona né a minha mensagem é de
esperança eu acho que a que esses novos
conceitos da neuroplasticidade que a
neurociência traz pra gente traz muita
esperança não é fácil todo mundo aqui
sabe que não é né mas precisa de um
trabalho existem também muitas coisas
novas
a questão da música também é a gente
entender o cérebro como é o cérebro
daquela criança do seu filho e descobriu
o caminho e a minha mensagem é essa de
esperança